un nobel de la paz para periodistas 85
años después la filipina maría reza y el
ruso dmitri murátov sucedieron al alemán
carl von ossietzky ganador en 1935
están recibiendo el premio nobel de la
paz por su valiente lucha por la
libertad de expresión en filipinas y en
rusia en rosa maria reza es directora
del portal digital rapper fue acusada
por difamación cibernética por un
artículo de 2012 que vinculaba a un
empresario con asesinatos narcotráfico y
trata de personas en 2018 reza fue
persona del año por la revista 'time' y
su trabajo le ha supuesto una
persecución legal en el último año
recibió diez órdenes de arresto
el premio nobel nos ayudará a hacer
brillar una luz más grande el periodismo
independiente que rinde cuentas del
poder nunca ha sido tan importante como
lo es hoy
suba y comparte el premio con dmitri
murátov el primer ruso en llevarse el
galardón desde la caída de la unión
soviética
el periodista ayudó a fundar nóvaya
gazeta en 1993
trabajo han destacado investigaciones a
gran escala sobre cuestiones de derechos
humanos corrupción y abuso de poder
desde que forma parte del periódico seis
de sus periodistas han sido asesinados
este premio es para nuestros
profesionales caídos que dieron su vida
por la profesión no soy el beneficiario
adecuado para el nobel sus
múltiples reacciones han llegado desde
el gremio de periodistas y
organizaciones de derechos humanos
la concesión del nobel de paz es una
señal poderosa un llamado a la acción
anda pero el action free and independent
yo el periodismo libre e independiente
es nuestro mejor aliado en la lucha
contra la desinformación this
information nadie sea su prestigio en
los últimos años el nobel de la paz ha
estado rodeado de polémica con
galardones como el de aviá comete en
2019 primer ministro de etiopía
actualmente en guerra con la región del
tigre